friends family colleagues coming
together in grief these were the nine
crew members of Ukraine International
Airlines who was supposed to land at
this terminal in Kiev or Wednesday it's
a tragedy for the whole world for
Ukraine and every one of us this is a
grief which is difficult to express in
words Ukraine's President Vladamir
Lansky joined the vigil he says
Ukrainian investigators are helping
Iranian authorities to find out why the
Boeing 737 crashed shortly after takeoff
from Tehran Airport join me I will speak
with Iran's president to step up
cooperation with Ukraine to establish
the truth I'm appealing to the
international community especially to
Canada to take part in the investigation
most the passengers were Iranian as well
as more than 60 Canadians in Toronto and
elsewhere in Canada there were more
candles more flowers and pictures of
those who'd been killed it really
shocked me as well as the Iranian
community and the world that this
happened I mean just think about the
lives that were lost and this was so
unnecessary Canada's Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau says this country will
make sure there's a proper investigation
our government will continue to work
closely with its partners to ensure that
this crash is thoroughly investigated
Canadians have questions and they
deserve answers video on social media
appears to show the Boeing 737-800 on
fire before it crashed in a city suburb
emergency crews on the ground work to
recover evidence from debris that was
scattered for several kilometers Ukraine
has canceled flights to Iran and says it
expects to see a transcription of the
black box cockpit recording the airline
says the plane was one of its best
and the pilots among its most
experienced it's a major setback for
Boeing which has struggled to regain
trust after the grounding of its 737 max
aircraft following two fatal air crashes
within five months there were many
nationalities on board as people
gathering grief around the world
investigators will want to find out why
the flight with a hundred and
seventy-six passengers and crew never
reached its destination
Laura Burton Manley al Jazeera